Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David P
here is a military veteran who says
I'm anti-American. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: David, hey, David, this is Bill from
Fayetteville, a retired Army officer. David,
I just want to know why you
seem to be so anti-American.
So when you see what Biden has done, which is
corruption, the amount of money, the hunter.
Speaker 1: So you said what
has Biden done? What Biden has
done. But now you're talking about Hunter.
Speaker 2: My family has done James Biden,
Hunter Biden. Why you don't want to discuss that.
Speaker 1: So notice that I that is something
we've discussed. And he says you want to
talk about what Biden has done but then
hasn't listed anything.
Speaker 2: Biden's done
the corruption of Uncle Joe and
10 percent goes to the big man,
Tony, bubble in ski and all that stuff.
Speaker 1: Yeah, we've covered all of that stuff.
Speaker 2: And, you know, you got you you like to
have your own country trashed by Omar and to lead.
Speaker 1: I have never spoke out and said
that my political heroes and guiding North Star
are ill Omar and Mashita to leave. So
it sounds like it's someone who's never
watched this show. Maybe. And the radical left.
Speaker 2: I was Solinsky afficionado there.
David, you know, I wonder David Pakman sounds
like to me like you might be from Jewish
forebears. That might have been good. God
fearing Jews. You see where Anadolu is to
remove the word God from the oath.
Speaker 1: And there it is,
my friends. And there it is. You don't
have to go too far until that comes up.
I present it with no further comment.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Don't miss it. Become a member at Join Pakman
Dotcom to get instant access. I will see you that.